Some viewer sent me this clip yesterday,
and I want to look at it with you today.
Evangelical end times televangelist pastor
preacher Rick Wiles did a commentary a few days
ago where he sort of sounded almost kind of like
maybe a populist leftist, certainly a populist,
maybe even a populist leftist who wants to take
money from billionaires to help the poor. And
some in our audience actually got suckered into
it initially. But if you actually listen to what
Rick Willes is saying and you understand the
context of his evangelical Christian worldview,
you realize he's merely being a conspiracy
theorist and a nutty one at that. It's plain,
old fashioned evangelical end times conspiracy
theory ism, which sometimes can sound like
its left wing populism, but it's not. Now,
before we get into the clip, as a reminder,
we've talked about Rick Willes before. He's one of
the guys who during the Trump administration was
talking about a civil war and taking up arms. He's
the guy that said the impeachment of Donald Trump
is an attempted juku. He said if Donald Trump is
removed, there will be violence. I guess he was
right about that. The violence was from people
on his side. He said vegan burgers are a satanic
plot to destroy souls. That's the Rick Willes
I'm talking about. So let's get into this clip.
And you might notice he starts sounding sort of
kind of like a left wing guy here. Take a listen.
If somebody in America put together a
political movement to do two main things.
Break up the power of the tech companies,
I mean, bust them up. Don't just. Slap
their fingers. Bust them up. Break them up
like the monopolies of the early 1990s, I mean,
crush the tech companies, break them up and. To.
Outlaw.
Being billionaires,
OK, he says, let's break up tech
companies, let's do antitrust enforcement,
that's often a left wing issue, except when they
only care about breaking up tech monopolies and
ignored the issue of antitrust for decades.
And then he said outlaw being a billionaire.
That's something many people on the left
have talked about. So so far, right wing
televangelist Rick Wiles is maybe appealing to
some folks in our audience. But let's continue.
We've reached the point. I mean, I'm a
free enterprise person and I have no.
No ill will towards anybody in their financial
success, i.e., hey, you want to be a zillionaire
zillionaire, I don't care, all right? You want
to go buy a planet, go by planet. I don't care.
But when you use your money and power to
change my life, to take away my rights,
to try to force things on me that I
object to, that I find morally repulsive,
when you try to restrict by free speech, when
you try to promote population control, you want
to pump vaccines into my body. When you want to
change society, you know what? You're my enemy.
You're my enemy. And the only way you're able
to do it is because you're a billionaire.
So then we need to take away your billions.
Bill Gates, if he was working a job.
Seven to five, if he was going to work like
everybody else, Bill Gates wouldn't be doing the
stuff with No. He's only doing this stuff because
he's a billionaire, take his billions away.
Take it away.
We need to do it in this country and there
needs to be a populous movement in this country.
Let's break up the tech companies. Let's take the
billions. Give the give. I want to take Bill
Gates has billions and give it to the poor.
So already, by this point, if you're a clear
thinking, rational person, you should start to say
this is this is wacky right wing stuff. It might
be dressed up in left populist sounding rhetoric.
But this is this is this is wacky stuff,
freedom for everyone until and then he's off the
rails. Anti vax conspiracies decrying left wing
morality that he claims is being imposed on him.
He's already off the rails, but maybe
some on the left might still be on board.
But then Rick Willes goes fully into
anti-government, anti-tax rants. Take a look.
I want to give it to the poor. I want to
strip them completely, strip them and give
it to the poor. I want Jack Dorsey's money. I want
Zuckerberg money. I want to give it to the poor.
I don't want to give it to the government, oh, my
gosh, taxman and the government get it now, give
it to the poor, let's take their money and give
it to the poor. This bust up their corporations,
this country would change overnight.
So now it's just standard right wing
thinking in just a few minutes he gets into the
government sucks, don't tax anyone. Let's depend
on charity to help the poor exclusively.
An old trope of the libertarian right.
That's all this is. And yet it's another example
of how populist sounding rhetoric can fool a lot
of people until you get to the solutions they
propose and the actions they take. This is the
Tucker Carlson syndrome. We can call it random
person who doesn't understand what Fox News is,
doesn't understand Tucker Carlson's background and
all that. They tune in to Tucker's show and they
hear Tucker ranting about corporations and elites
doing bad things to the little guy. And we were
told that we were going to have a reinvigoration
of the working class and all this stuff.
Wow. That sounds almost like Bernie. And then it
gets too careful. Black Lives Matter might take
your house. Brown people coming in from Mexico
make the country dirtier. Literally a quote from
Tucker Carlson. It's just another example of that
sweet, sweet vocabulary of the populist rhetoric
that tricks people. And then you get to the
solutions they propose. And it's standard radical
right wing stuff. Yeah, monopolies are bad.
Billionaires are bad. Help the poor. And then,
whoa, what just happened here?
So there is Rick Willes calling
what I call the pulling what I call the
old populist switcheroo and actually
tricking some people even in my audience.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.